in East my name's on the krump I will be
Qian tonight's meeting and if we could
make sure phones are turned off I've
still got mine on at the moment because
it's Shakespeare's birthday this week
and I thought I'd do three quotes from
all that glitters is not gold I catch
the site the official quote yes mr.
Barker the course of true love never did
run smooth safe at a price to anybody
and to lie down south be true and it
must follow as the night the day thou
canst not then be false to any man so
there we are a bit of culture before we
start I'd just like to introduce the top
table Thank You chair mr. Forester
committee services
good evening my name's Dale Barker I'm a
planning manager in my role as an
impartial adviser to the committee I can
clarify any planning issues that arise
doing so I'm bound by the code of
Professional Conduct at the Royal Town
Planning Institute planning committee
members are not bound by the case
officers recommendation or by any oral
advice nutty coin planner Louise Casey
planner Victoria chatter a Senior
Planner Vincent why would you County
Council highways thank you first on item
on the agenda apologies for absence
thank you very much item to dispose of
interest cash the pie
good evening chair just want to advise
that I attended a site meeting at
pollutant priors 19 forward slash zero
zero one three nine forward slash fall
and I'm also known to the wife of one of
the objectors speaking on behalf the
residents but I don't believe this will
have an impact
I come to the meeting with an open mind
Thank You chair with across the same
application I will be stepping down
about that when that's being heard so I
can represent it thank you I see
I'm cancellous st. was there as well
yes counselor st. was there that meeting
and also I'm known to the applicant over
the wounded sin Road Broyles application
but I don't think that will affect my
judgment in dealing with that one thank
you very much
and I will declare an interest on
application 1803 to 39
it's my County Council ward and I've
been covering the ward number the
district Cancer Council Williams so I am
known to the agent the applicant and I
will not be taking part and with us
catch the Perry to chair in my absence
thank you
yes you're right how many of us have
received the emails from mr. Sanchez on
the application 18 / 0 3 2 3 9 I think
somehow hungry I think I've received yep
catch the bastard you have an up okay an
email from mr. Sanchez that one email
yes so I think all the committee yep
bring if we could just know faces right
item 3 can I have your approval to the
sauna minutes of the meeting out on the
27th of February in the 20th March
please thank you
right thank you very much ants on those
shortly this I'm going to slightly amend
the running order and hopefully we won't
divide proceedings by two too much first
of all I would like to bring application
number seven she's 19 / 0 0 1 3 9 / ful
Lund off Bumbry road you know pollutant
priors and what to bring that one
forward and the reason for that is album
say I'll be assuming you're agreeing to
that sorry I'll start if is on to
something but thank you very much yes
please down thank you the reason for
bringing this application forward is
that we are recommending that members
defer the application to a later
committee the reason for that
recommendation
I'm sorry counselor yes understood
the reason for that recommendation is
that at the site inspection on Tuesday
there was a question raised over whether
the proposed hedge was in the
application site or not we're looking to
bring forward to you a clear answer on
that actually at the next committee but
until we have a clear answer into we're
clear that we have control over the edge
we'd like you to be free to allow us to
do further work thank you Jeff looking
for proposal and seconder to the Korean
cancer cancer Kendall proposed cancer
per second all those in favor
thank you catch the st. are you person
or not
upstate Thank You committee resolves to
divert application 90 and says that 139
ful slight change to the running order
again but will become obvious why bring
forward again if committee can agree to
bring forward application 18 slashes ro3
766 fu owl 8 to 9 browse industrial
state Winterton road by rails a great
server bring that one forward all those
in favor
yep all right
so Dale would you like to Matthew
Thank You Sherman so the applications
that committee start because the the
parish council had objected country to
recommendation they've not registered to
speak received and so we're inviting
members to delegate it to officers to
ground in accordance with the report
because the parish council happened to
arrive tonight so counts the barns
propose and cancel field in a second
that we delegate to officers all those
in favor only against any abstentions
results to delegate application to 18 /
zero three seven six six everywhere to
delegate to officers for decision thank
you
right I think it was so you know I move
on to the first application to be heard
in forward tonight is application
eighteen / 0 3 0 4 5 ful Lund at
Washington the underground installation
of electricity to the communication and
water supply connections to the longest
in turn would tunnel northern portal to
service the tunnel boring machine TPM
and Victoria's our percent officer thank
you Thank You chair planning consent is
sought for the installation of
electricity telecommunications and water
supply connections to be laid under the
existing highway in order to serve a
tunnel boring machine needed as part of
the construction of HS to the root of
the the road under which the utilities
would be laid is depicted in this slide
[Applause]
it's proposed that a standard trenching
methodology would be used to create the
trench within which to lay these
utilities this involves the excavation
of the trench with soil temporarily
reinstalled adjacent to the trench
utilities would then be placed within
the trench on the ground reinstated with
the vote instated on top this slide
illustrates the indicative phasing and
timing of the works the proposed works
are temporary in nature and where
possible the developer seeks accord
networks with existing road closures
proposed with other developers in
carrying out works within the HS to
limit the developer is bound by their
code of construction practice and
although outside of the HS to act
boundary the applicant is committed to
adhering to these practices and carrying
out these works check there are updates
to this application which have been
provided in your update sheet the
recommendation is to grant planning
permission subject to a suitable legal
agreement which is sought to secure the
provision of additional buses needed
during the school term times whilst
diversions are in place and subject to
the conditions listed thank you
obviously the update seat is quite
comprehensive so I'll give members a
couple of minutes to just make sure that
fully understand the update sheet before
we call the first speaker so if you
could indicate once you're happy and
I'll just pause the meeting whilst you
read the Apaches
I've never heard a real of cancellous so
quite so which is dr. Dan Mitchell mr.
Mitchell but to want courtly yes please
is yeah yes place yep
thank you so yeah we need the mic on so
it goes out on the webcast we don't
charge any extra facism thank you you
got three minutes mr. Mitchell would
like a warning with 30 seconds to go no
dream lots is plenty super far away
thank you Jim
I live at Baskin eath so going down the
sea 97 row through Busby Heath has a
major impact on our community what I
should also point out is 150 acres of
ancient woodland Nebraska he and any
disturbance along that road will disturb
the roots of the trees will also disturb
the wildlife but I'm here basically to
support the objections I've put in I'm a
chartered engineer and engineers are
trained to optimize and in this case
that is not an optimized route for the
cable the water supply and the telecoms
I've been involved with hs2 since the
start of the project and I was involved
in extending the tunnel to two
kilometers because it made sense to do
so
compared with a one kilometer trench
through the Polo Grounds so my
objections are based on the fact that
the engineer's have not optimized the
job to optimize it you would either take
a straight line to wood farm from the C
97 pay four to five Junction the
crossroads or you'd do what we discussed
in London years ago which is to use stem
by generators for the power supply
that's all I really want to say hm
very much any questions for mr. dr.
Mitchell yep well you came with a
technical question Oh talk which I can't
understand because I'm not technically
but the wildlife but admitted I was
concerned about can you elaborate on
that yes certainly
I mean the woods have about 150 monk
check deer that's quite a herd they
regularly get culled by traffic going on
that road we have bats we have barn owls
we have badgers you name it we've got it
we have sparrowhawks we have we have a
whole range well there have been surveys
of various farms close to the woods
I mean surveyors from all over Britain
and none of them know the others have
come I only found where we're coming
from okay thank you sorry that's the
road that goes through basket Heath so
if you see the green patch for the woods
and you see the tunnel at the top yeah
then that orange bit is going straight
through that is the scene 97 Fox and hen
at one end and the lemming tomorrow at
the other thank you
good evening could you elaborate a bit
more about the standby generators you
mentioned which would be an alternative
method yes I worked electricity industry
as an engineering manager for most of my
career and we use generators in many
situations you all know that hospitals
have generators most large premises have
generators and in the initial
discussions we concluded in London this
is seven or eight years ago that the
optimum way to supply the power would be
to use generators and that would simply
mean the lorries would drive in connect
up to the tunnel boring machine do the
job and withdraw now that would negate
the need for all the trenching pretty
clear most okay thanks very much for
listening to the microphone dr. Mitchell
please and whoever next speaker please
which is mr. Allen Payne and pick us by
you were hiding right you that's why it
was alright gentlemen you've got three
minutes between you again would you like
a warning with 30 seconds to go or you
think I'm okay Thank You mr. chairman
Allen Payne high-speed to senior project
manager for the section which includes
the tunnel and longer Tintin would this
is a twin 10 meter diameter board tunnel
using a TPM tunnel boring machine
they're very specific and basically the
design of the machine wasn't finalized
until ground conditions were known and
we needed a contractor on board to tell
us what power requirements are required
it's not included into the high speed to
act because the route wasn't known at
that point in time
so we've elected to come through the
planning process rather than falling
back on Santos actually Undertaker
powers as an independent connection
provider so the objective objective is
to provide water electricity and
telecoms to the TBM we're also taking
the opportunity as well to replace some
services in Vasco teeth Road above the
tunnel which won't be vulnerable to any
settlement asbestos cement water mains
in particular we've consulted consulted
with WPD Western power and National Grid
and they've concluded that the spare
capacity for something of this size is
it's a harpy's substation hence the that
we have selected the plan map and while
sorting putting together a phasing plan
there are always conflicting local
requirements which we need to take
account of some relays with Warwickshire
County Council and Stratford District
Council in particular regarding their
concern around the timing and the road
safety improvements you want to carry
out on me associated with the housing
development light one Heath so the
phasing depan is basically built around
the window of opportunity to allow that
work to be carried out in the back end
of this year we also had representations
with and that was actually subjective
representation - Jeremy right as well so
we have closed the other concern that
was raised was around the bus routes and
school holidays
so we've actually timing that as well
announce that the road is closed is
closed during the school holidays which
mitigators the impact on school buses
during the term time and we've also
agreed to sign a bilateral agreement
with the council to provide costs of any
increased bus services required as a
point coming up arising from that there
is phase 1 which is actually we're using
a road closure implemented by david
wilson homes under section 2 7 8
agreement with Warwickshire so this is
not our very closure but we are
obviously taking the opportunity to use
that arose closure to mitigate the
overall pact of delays on there if we
don't do that then we'd also have to
come back and close that road again
at the future date but so we were taking
the opportunity to minimize the
disruption where we can the first road
closure for under high speed 2 is phase
2 showing off section 2 shown on there
which is the 10th of June so questions
cast aside sir yes chairman mr. Payne
made reference to we had to make a
decision because at the time of the Act
the route wasn't known I would challenge
that because at the time of the Act
going through
I was leader of this council and
involved in quite a lot of and you go
the oceans in conjunction with local
parishes and local ward members and
effectively they're always right from
the outset been envisaged to tunnel
under long Edgington Ward so I would
argue that the route wasn't having it
and therefore this committee needs to be
aware of decision making process on that
basis okay can we try and stick to
questions if possible I can understand
what you're saying that Kansas a clear
war of a question next time please that
councillor fielding well if there's a
question chairman would mister play and
revise his statement that the route
wasn't known when it wasn't the routes
of high-speed to was now the route of
any reinforcements and supplies to the
tunnel boring machine was not known at
that time so apologies if that wasn't
misunderstood
is that possible and how long if you did
put generators would there be a
permanent so we've done a review of that
it would take 20 generators each the
size of a container lorry so you'd need
fuel to refuel although so you've got
tankers coming environmental impacts of
running all that off diesel it's this is
a more cost-effective solution overall
it's not just power its water and
telecom so we would still need to do at
least half of the route to bring other
services in so and there's also
potential to turn this into supply to
feed the tunnel ventilation system at
the end of the day so it likelihood it
would all be required regardless
different use generators for the
tunneling work dakari we just wave into
you know
obviously you've done some form of
consultation with you say Western power
that's not good National Grid the County
Council regarding the additional buses
potentially because of the road closure
but you're trying to minimize that song
just some clear by working at the same
time the road closure with a section two
seven eight we david wilson correct yep
so if you weren't able to coincide with
the david wilson and road closure what
would be the additional time scale we
would have to tag another six weeks on
and close that road again
at the future date okay thank you you're
free to go thank you
right our next speaker is cancer kettle
just a point I'm slightly concerned that
the update sheet does not concern
contain the full text there are a number
of emails have not included quotes from
emails which I included in that text
which have been excluded I'll fix it
wasn't going to the District Council I
just like to make that point are from
businesses that have not been consulted
at all about this process just confirm
that there was data protection issues
which we assessed so that's why the
emails were removed from the update
sheet Richard hence the kettle is
adjoining ward member and it was part of
his previous or adjacent adjacent reward
so in order to make sure we fully did
about this properly
his pencil riches and cancer house can't
attend and councillor kettle
sorry cancer house didn't say that and
we just need to slightly adjourn there
with fewer subjects on the Vice from
dial and Mason
sorry about that
cats kettle cancer heresy against the
house if you won't stop first and then
can schedule finish off and you've got
five minutes between you go on then on
this occasion madness between you though
chairman just asked why it's five
minutes between them because he usually
ate each council would be given five
minutes total each have written Li caps
the Harris indicated that she couldn't
come all those possibilities you might
arrive late so cancel the kettle was
going to substitute and I did that as
Chairman's discretion to ensure
democracy is seen and heard properly
caps the Harris managed to get here on
time and I didn't see her so apologies
for that to make sure that no they're
both here again the joining Ward member
and the warden mode but I think is
opportunity for both of them to speak so
decision Thank You chairman I can say
I'm not substituting and I had no
intention to substitute for my neighbor
as you know spoken to mr. weeks this
morning who confirmed by email I would
entitled speak as adjoining board member
because they're a significant impact of
this development on my patch now I'm
very happy to try and squeeze both our
bits into five minutes yeah we'll move
on I'm using my discussion now we've
moved on we probably spent more than
five minutes talking about this so if
you could do yours if decide which one
is going to go first do that first and
then second one speak and then we've got
five minutes between you and they will
carry on okay
right this application affects the town
village to sow them Harbury Bishop's
Katyn at the minimum Hsu is a flagship
policy for the UK and this is not a
challenge to that policy for the UK it's
about a local amendment to the scheme
and it's whether that local amendment
complies with our core strategy and the
NPP f the long-term effects will clearly
be invisible and we have no argument
about the landscape bill quality or
design in one of the other planning
things that we hear the sole issue here
is economic and whether the impact for
this district is acceptable the
application will effectively close be
double for five one stroke - from
Junction for bishop search engine which
is the root for Junction 12 and jlr and
Aston Martin to start them at any point
seized the County Council in its
response has described it as as causing
severe disruption through road network
and the letter dated 18 December as a
totally objected to this application
you've read had an opportunity to read
my comments what you've not had an
opportunity is here what what local
businesses have to say about it so and
I'm going to quote and accept that you
you've got the updating she's in front
of you mr. Wilder it's been brought to
my attention that the road between
harbours in depth the bridges to be
closed for 12 months period it was
recently closed for several weeks which
caused disruption to our business as we
have a lot of HTV and business traffic
coming to us from the m-40 that closure
was to enable the enabling works for
this the diversion version options are
limited and get either give huge and
complicated detours and all collide with
jlr aston martin at peak times which is
nightmare in itself works they were not
consulted
Warwick steel structures were not
consulted at or informed work steel
structures were on a steel construction
fabrication business based at DEP is
bridge in Section two we have many large
HGVs coming in to our site on a daily
basis when the road round Harbury were
closed recently the chaos or renewing
these large vehicles will just work all
night man
we rely on still being delivered by Road
wagons cannot come over Epis bridge
because of a weight restriction the
chaos caused during the last rope
closures saw several of our delivery
films refused to come to us until the
roads have been reopened now I ask how
these road closures are forced upon us
for approximate 12 months and how we're
supposed to get materials into our site
veterinary practice when this red ones
previously shut at the end of 2018 we
were similarly given no notification
we're therefore unable to walk clients
for the closure the devotion with bad
design difficult follow-up unreasonable
causing chaos and making plans late for
appointments very first stage and on
occasions gave up closure of this road
will cause significant disruption to my
business masquerade in Southam were
concerned about the impact we'll have an
orange TV deliveries inbound to our
southern site as well as our daily
occurring of the cups we're not aware we
are not aware of any impending road
closures in relation to hs2 that email
came today
Dallas postman supersedes any written or
verbal communication about the 12-month
road closures which is due to take place
on the beat on four five one to Tesco's
I'm able to find anybody who's been
communicated to this work we are unaware
of the impact southern tiles had no
point is they were consulted us about
the work sound tars on the m-40 which
would you to start shortly and they will
have a make huge impact on our
deliveries with other deliveries and my
delivery vehicles to gain access the
motor we've had no response from
workshop Fire and Rescue Service
how a fire trucks getting across this
barrier there are viable alternatives
which have been used by jlr and Western
power where they buried the cable just
over a minute
Thank You chair I won't be very long
obviously I'm supporting what councillor
kettle says also draw the attention to
Harvey parish councils concerns about no
traffic management scheme for impact on
local roads or any finer detail there's
concerned around HGTV's leaving the m-40
junction 12 and then clear pathway
through as you're all aware my ward is
suffering from major projects there will
be the hardly cross roads commencing
often roundabouts the jail our trophy
the gated road at Chesterton and
Kingston will be closed and the mo d AG
aid and we'll be starting its roadworks
a fourth meetings with Jeremy white HS
to another members to the table to
discuss the other consider overgrown
concern that strategically especially
with County highways nobody is managing
this and please the HS to have been
coming to meetings they have been
listening but sometimes I fear not being
hearing I think this is important that
you look at this tonight that the
overall traffic management scheme for HS
- is not fit for purpose and needs a
closer scrutiny we need a clearer
management scheme of the impact on local
roads not just for residents but it is
impacting on businesses they have not
consulted with jlr either okay you sneak
that one in cancer cutting right right
questions for the ward members
associated members are joining members
whatever title on the record cancer
cattle and the council house catch the
bonds the speakers before you have you
spoken to them of what I'm trying to
ascertain ease I wouldn't mind having
them back to ask him about HPV but I'm
trying to find out has there been any
communication locally with them no just
the reason why I was late this evening
counts of bounces I had to go to
deputies bridge to a really fraught
meeting there with local residents
regarding the issues surrounding the
wait bridge there and speeding along
that roads they're very concerned about
what pathway and the impact on them is a
rat run with HTV the wait bridge and
speeding and burden any routes
there's no clear plan we're pulling
together locally what we can do but
there's been no engagement with them
from anyone I just can't ask this
question again cotton you asked us to
wear obviously I'm trying to get to the
bottom of this age TVs and the future
alum but if you like the point bill is
we can't ask the applicant can we ask
the county councillors
we've got the county capsule officer
said will they have imports of
clarification and discussions once we
finished with the ward members and again
we can always ask the applicants to come
back as well bricen can I respond to my
on my behalf to you can't slip ask you a
question thank you
sorry I think the question though the
question I have attended different
meetings sorry I'm not I'm really upset
that okay everyone I tried to speak mr.
Nash tries to interact well yet that way
cuz I please answer the questions that
counselor Barnes has asked which I've
been to different meetings to councillor
Harris which what councillor Harris
would not necessarily be aware of what's
gone on I think it's important that this
committee should be allowed to hear on
this major issue about my meetings that
mics if you could keep it brief then on
this occasion Thank You mr. chairman I
turn to the meeting with JL are they
have a gate in the Azon group a member
of Lang Murphy joint-venture who's a
subcontractor
announced to the director of Jett the
jlr site on the 15th of April that was
the first time that director who's
responsible for gayden had been told
about the proposed road closures
consultation with them was minimal
I've listed eight businesses who I've
spoken to
and if Dale could put my map up know my
motto yeah
understand that there have been some
communication those first five
businesses of subsequent open to three
more including Tesco's in Southam those
five businesses ring the road closure
none of them have had any consultation
from hs2 or their joint venture partner
about the road closures in fact I was
the first person
miss jeren question for councillor
Harris
she's been on about a meeting a DEP Asst
bridge and the concerns of DEP as bridge
now if you look at the map on page 23 of
our agenda
he's got grid squares on and if they're
Ordnance Survey maps these grid squares
or one kilometer across no question
about it that means that the residence
is in depth as bridge are three
kilometers from long-reaching tomate so
why should they be that concerned
because the road closures diverged new
routes are the traffic finding ways
through the road closures it will
increase through Depot's there's no
clear pathway for the HGTV's and there's
a weight restriction on the bridge
through there and the increase of HGTV's
going through there what we need is a
clear traffic management plan signage
etc etc diverting hdvs and other heavy
lorries away from that area because they
will just use the Sutton house and go
through there
any further questions for the ward
members no you're free to go
thank you it's just to let counsel state
know that the work starts at Bishop so
it does affect that excuse me sorry
thank you
right thank you very much right mr.
Mitchell
dr. Mitchell I'm afraid you can't on
this no sorry unless committee requests
for you to come back on a point for
clarification I can't ask you to come
back I'm afraid no it's a point that
they need to raise a clarification but
nobody's indicated that they want to to
do that on this arm read in the room
wrong right thank you very much we'll
move on the points of clarification
okay so st. I've asked one or two
questions now because I'm confused now
it seems to me I've been aware as I said
earlier of the tunnel under long
reaching to move for about four or five
years and I remember arguments about it
its length and everything else with the
war member counts that reaches and the
discussions that we had at the time also
there is the issue of the Polo Grounds
as well that it affected but what we go
on here is a line which has a road
closure which is concerning councillor
Harris and I now understand why my
explanation was quite clear but the
thing is that we have a situation would
be been far better if we'd have been
given a map that showed the route of hs2
we were given a map that showed the
diversions that are necessary and
everything else and perhaps these can be
clarified I will get to hearts light in
a minute
so this plan does actually show the
route of hs2 through it so that the
planning application relates only to the
utilities works proposed which is the
area shown in the the multicolors just
to show the phasing but the route is the
black line and the blue line either side
of it and so where's the a for to
whatever it is along there
where's this road that's gonna have to
be tunneled under to do this word so
that the tunnel is the black line the
deep black line so as on the key it says
HS too long it chintan tunnel the HS to
trace so the actual line is is either
side of that and the road die sex that
so we've got we've got number one shows
a the I'm afraid I don't know which is
that oh okay sorry I'm gonna have to
work off Google Maps but bear with me so
all right when marker one is the blue
bottom bit that is the B four four five
one at DEP is bridge going over to
Debbie's bridge the red parcel part two
is the B for four five to never eat once
you forgot a vote name phase three is
the B for four five to heading north
obviously that's north of hard way which
is from the junction with but slang to
the south which is not colored we then
head up to the crossroad Junction sorry
the T Junction of the a45 to lement
invade note down that one there yeah
ya know the Google's Google saying it's
the a45 yeah and then obviously we go on
to a country lane which then connects up
to well flame which is five and then
four obviously as well throughout sigh
well throwed heading off towards the the
proposed substation compound so that
that's the road network it's a it's a
mixture of be roads and then the C Road
emotional members I was gonna spend
we've got several points as the points
that counts of cattle cattle raised the
points of cancer site rise is the issue
of guard in the section two seven might
the David Wilson as well so I think
there are several points that you want
to clarify them though I can just before
Ben explains and the application before
you doesn't seek to close the road
that's a consequence of the development
that's not what the proposal is for so
when you grant planning permission you
don't grant the closing of roads that
dealt with under separate legislation
and under separate permits and obviously
HS to have had to be in consultation
with the county and everybody else in
seeking those road closures in the
ambition that should planning consent be
granted they will then seek permits and
everything else from that but just for
clarification in determining this
application that's a separate process
we're just determining the application
before us which is to dig a trench and
put utilities within it and then close
that back up but then can certainly
clarify discussions that have occurred
yep so I've had an in-depth induction I
hate just to team is afternoon so bear
with me but firstly you've heard a
comment about section 278 works with
David Wilson homes and that pages two
are going to be utilizing those works
that hasn't been agreed yet by the
County Council there is because
obviously we got to make a planning
decision tonight and then certain town
folks go through we may not align with
those works also those works are going
through technical approval with the
County Council and whilst they've got
the road space booked there might be an
issue which causes them to be delayed
etc so that hasn't been agreed yet we
will try minimize the risk between the
two where we can but there is a
potential that the two don't come
together the road won't be closed for a
period of 12 months in total the works
are phased and that's shown in that plan
so it will be closed in sections during
that time so it's not going to be closed
in one whole lot and closed for that
whole period certain islands we've open
and so therefore they can take the
traffic there will be diversion boots
unfortunately from my position I don't
have clear view of what those diversion
routes that are at the moment I asked
our team and they don't either
we will work with HST to ensure suitable
diverging routes are put in place to
control that but as Victoria said you
know that's not really what we're
considering here tonight in that basis
the final comments I just want to make
is relation to the fire and rescue
comment made by councilor kettle the
County Council will set out a clear
statement actually and has shared that
with parish councils and town councils
on on the routes and the county councils
hs2 team has we dizzily designed a
process for notifying blue light
services of any disruption to watch this
highway network caused by the
construction of the high speed railway
this is including an upgrade and
modernization of the systems that
ensures that its responses to incidents
are unhindered by temporary road
closures and other traffic management
issues across the whole of Warwickshire
the hs2 team has been tasked we were
placed in the comment paper
based information with modern solution
which is now being implemented to
provide key information electronic
information quickly and clearly and
that's been done through the control
room for the Fire and Rescue Service in
addition when roads are closed we have
to make sure accesses maintained for all
emergency vehicles thank you thank you I
just wonder whether the weather Ben can
just expand upon the communication as
far as the traffic management what what
the procedure would be to ensure all
businesses are made aware it would
appear at the moment that project fear
has has come about because clearly they
don't know about it because actually no
decision has been made and no traffic
management plan with the proposed
diversions so I just find it helpful to
hear from you what the process would be
to be able to ensure vital businesses
and the economy around that area are
protected from getting goods in and out
so those details have been confirmed yet
because we haven't agreed set dates with
hey Chester - obviously once that
discussion and agreement has been made
then there'll be a process of
consultation with the residents and
businesses but I would that would be
down to hate just to to inform those as
it's their works and that's the same
with house builders where we try to
County highways will advertise them as
well in terms of the permits through
local communication facilities but as
well we do rely upon good communications
as well from the developers in this case
just - but David Wilson homes would have
had to do that as well we would expect
it as part of the higher authority at
the moment I can't really say because we
still got to agree the timescales yeah
I've got a question but one of the other
concerns that local parish councils and
ten councils say about regarding
diversions
is the communication of bus routes
obviously we're talking about school bus
trips here in particular but the
ordinary bus routes get changed and the
the information that comes out from
stagecoach can be tardy or potentially
inaccurate to say the least
so again if this committee could send a
message across the side that whoever's
in charge of those areas again they need
to tell the members of the public in
particular parish councils and
accountants about town councils in the
area that they need to ensure the bus
timetables are clearly communicated when
there's a bus when there's a diversion
report in place that's that I'll get
into several parish council meetings and
I've always been budgeted by that so
again probably taking a bit of a Liberty
by having a little runt here but if we
could pass that message through as well
[Music]
we both said that but I'm not sure if
it's a planning aspect is that if you're
putting the onus on the developer to
ensure there's good liaison and
communication just taking on board the
feedback from the ward member the
neighbouring ward member about project
Ferris as councillor Perry accurately
called I think is there any way we can
insist that there's almost like a
liaison group or something like that to
set up the that cut the communication
because you're putting the onus on the
developer and it's not necessarily going
to meet the needs that have been set up
by the fact there's been this lack of
communication thus far as I understand
it H is to provide a lot of information
sorry future on their website and that
is relatively available to members of
the community watch accounts Council in
our function as well is trying to get
messages out and it's been proactive in
communications as well through our
parish councils and town councils the
recommend the matter you're raising is
one for use help yourselves to decide
when you think that's necessary as a
note
mr. your deliberation so I think the
lies I was just been given is that we
couldn't insist it was a condition but
we could make it as a note as part of
the application catch the Barnes and
cancel fielding it seems to be a totally
different application now we've had the
officers and telling us there will be
the ozone and that compared with what we
were led to believe earlier on that's my
personal opinion that seems to be a
situation we could ask I think that the
area's own thing just carry on and and
keep abreast of it which will be a good
thing yeah I think I'm just to sort your
comments there cats advance I think
you're saying that with the Internet's
we want to add in all the comments that
the committee have made so far
we seem to have strengthened the
application in terms of communication
the eyes on etc and given that warning
to the turns and parish councils in the
area so I think that's what you're
trying to say but is that okay well you
pretty better than make it out that I
favor but that's where we are we've
still got a few more points it's my it's
just based on the age of the but you're
saying that we the town and parish
councils and also businesses in the area
must be given fair warning so that they
can either apply for compensation
just to if that is and I think there's
two separate things there isn't I mean
obviously the planning application was
consulted upon as part of the process
for that I can't speak for what's in the
details of the HS to act and how
businesses would deal with that that I
think would be a matter between any
local businesses and HS to
how good right we'll move on to the
debate now who would like to start on
this one then shall I start then
obviously we've heard from dr. Mitchell
regarding his concern about the
generators and that could be an
alternative provision and then we've
heard from Mr Pyne who you actually said
it would involve at least 20 container
lorry type size and generators that
would have to be processed and fed with
water oil etc I'm just summarizing you
know I mean but there would potentially
environmental issues there and would not
consider so we've heard from from them
we've heard from the ward members who've
got concerns about the application and
the communications that we've seem to
have spoken about to move us to make
notes as part of this application and
again we've moved past a clear message
on to the County Council Farben what we
would like to see happen if any of
things if this application were to be
approved so we've had the term project
fear which I didn't think got here
tonight but we've heard it tonight
I'll come to you in a minute so done so
we've got we need to make sure we are
looking at this in the bunny application
so I think we've had quite a fair crack
of the whip in terms of discussion and
the points of clarification and but I
just need to make sure members are aware
what we are considering the Gardiners
application so a small little speech but
cancer o'donnell then cuts the pie and
whilst we've had a fair crack of the
whip is it too late to just get a point
of clarification for one of the speakers
about the the generators
because the first speaker mentioned them
as an option then the applicant said it
wasn't possible but I wondered what the
first speaker felt about that with
regards to his recommendations regarding
generators I would just on this occasion
as long as dr. Mitchell is quite brief
and to the point I think I understand
where the gentleman's coming from but
when we have a planning application in
front of us we require to assess the
application that's in front of us so
this is what we're here to assess we're
not here to assess an alternative option
we're here to assess this application as
detailed and the planning merits of that
come back take on board the comments why
Victoria but again just to make sure
everybody is clear and aware so again
Kent's Road Donald's got her question
answered I will let you come back
briefly on that dr. Mitchell if you like
to come forward
I challenge what mr. Paine said twenty
generators that's ridiculous I spent
most of my career in the electricity
industry and if I was sat next to other
electrical engineers that statement will
be shot down and I think you need to
know that thank you very much
thank you right okay well go back now
again I'll just remind everybody the
point the Victoria just made about the
application before us so cats for Perry
was nected you indicate next after and
then castithan Thank You chair and also
I think we've had some some good
speakers come forward with some really
good information together with the
clarification from Highways which has
been extremely helpful we are looking at
the planning application before us we
haven't got to the stage of traffic
management plans because the highways
haven't worked out the routes there is a
lot of consultation to go forward I feel
we've got a comfort factor because we've
addressed the concern and you know I do
feel that the will be the consultative
long as the the businesses are informed
which I feel the way highways are
approaching it they will and on that
note I am happy to propose that we go
with the officers recommendation and
what we have in front of us we are not
engineers around this table we are
judging this as a planning application
and we have the reassurance from
Warwickshire highways that an
appropriate traffic management scheme
will be put in this is a phase delivery
we've had reassurance that is not going
to be closed for 12 months I think the
most important thing is for the ward
members to go back and take what is
actually the state of this application
that the traffic management plan is to
be put in place it will involve
consultation so to avoid project fear
being incurred from people thinking some
they're roads all around them are going
to be enclosed when we haven't even got
to that stage so I am very happy to
propose this application
filled in on about June 2nd cancer
cancer fairly I think counselor Perry
said it's a chicken and egg situation
here we've got to get this approval
through first in order that highways can
start liaison and also developing their
approach to it so I'm quite happy to
second it I've got cancer st. I thought
you were going to take your point first
well I'm sorry to dent councilor Perry's
enthusiasm I am a chartered engineer and
I am sitting around this table as a
member of this planning committee and
therefore I have a view on the various
comments that dr. Mitchell and mr. Payne
have put forward and I think perhaps
there is a better solution but certainly
doesn't involve 20 generators however I
haven't looked it in that much detail so
I shouldn't say too much and I'm not
here to give you a professional advice
anyway I'm here as a member of the
committee to work as Victoria says on
the application in front of us which is
to dig a bloomin trench under a road and
then you know make certain that
everything's tidied up in the process I
am very pleased to hear Ben talk about
the consultation from the County Council
with local parishes I think that he's
vitally important and although I can't
discuss it I'm leaving consultation over
another application in my patch which is
nowhere near here as you well know where
effectively that consultation did not
take place by the County Council I know
I can't discuss that tonight I'm not
going to so I'm very encouraged to hear
that the proper consultation has taken
place with local parishes about the
impact of these proposals
to me hs2 has to come I'm not an over
enthusiastic supporter of it but having
worked hard in the past to make certain
that long issuing tomb would is
protected by a tunnel I think we have to
look at the facilities that go with it
so I'm happy to support the proposal
which we follow the officers
recommendation catch the kettle and
catch the house they've indicated they
want to come back with some points of
collocation have you got any questions
or any points of clarification you want
to raise with them as ward members
council is this material so is anybody
have any points of clarification I'm
just concerned again can catch the bonds
concern it does appear that's the
present time they aren't in the loop if
you read the Farmers Weekly every week
is the same problem all the way along
this line with farmers villages houses
probably now so what I'm saying is if we
can assure that both of the ward members
and I appreciate there's a selection and
hopefully they will both be back I kept
in the loop that's the important thing
to the pier they're not at the moment
but if we can ensure that I think we're
moving in the right direction right
chance the kettle
I will on this occasion ask you just to
clarify your point you new rising
concerns about but again I expect you to
be brief and to the point
counselors of a project fear I am
quoting directly from a communications
manager of Lange Murphy joint venture
partner who confirmed that the effect of
the road closures because they're done
consecutively will be sections one that
will be closed followed immediately by
section two following reason by section
3 which will have the impact of closing
that are maids of that an extended
period project fear is not looking at
the actuality and we have responsible
can I actually touch them more question
that's why I asked you to come back have
you got evidence from that I think it
was like Murphy questioned that this was
going to happen or they are because I
copied and I sent an email which I
copied to Mister
[Music]
the comments that you've received are
inaccurate and they are subject to some
form of have been so the comments that
have been raised by councilor kettle of
being identified as misleading by the
County Council and the County Council
has taken appropriate action to resolve
that matter therefore we have to be very
careful with the information that has
been communicated in certain
circumstances
therefore what I've told you this
evening is correct in terms of the
phasing and its development information
at this time yes thank you it's a party
associated with them not necessary just
a stop there any more points of
clarification cancer that Harris had
keep this brief please if you can I will
keep it brief
I commend it on the journey last July
over the issues around hs2 and the admit
that we've had dialogue involving even
Jeremy right because initially they were
not listening are certainly not hearing
it's good to hear what been saying
tonight because we had to drag County to
this meeting because there was no
strategic overview I have to agree and I
share with you that the landscape is
changing things are improving council
Fielding's right it is a chicken and egg
situation but we do need to note and
hold County to account that we have this
traffic management plan because this is
an isolation this planning right tonight
but across my whole Ward area it's
saturated with projects that are causing
problems taking this off and they've
agreed a traffic management plan so I'm
asking you as a committee this
application we have to deal with what's
in front
of us but I understand your concerns
about the whole thank you I think we'll
right okay you're free to go in that
concise and we won't have any more
points of clarification I'll take your
points on board but again we have to
make sure we are dealing with this
application even there are our concerns
about the whole process right we've had
a proposal and a second recommendation
Perry are you happy to take that we've
got so happy to take up the operated
recommendation and to ask for a notes to
be placed on the community where the
community is or not everyone looks on a
website we said about community yet just
so it's not they just look at the
website protest to there has to be a you
know intergenerational cuz not one uses
website yeah gamma just on the section
106 agreement due to a legal technical
issue it can actually be cannot be a
section 106 agreement has to be just a
contract between the county district and
a Chester to I won't bore you with the
legal details but they've been clarified
by all three parties right so we've had
a proposal on a second to accept agree
the recommendation with the amended
recommendation or additional
recommendation um notes so all those in
favor
so committee resolved to grant
application 18 star zero three zero four
five ful I will step aside subpoena
right good evening and thank you for
your patience while we have a quiet
space and time right we now move on my
name is Anne Perry and vice chairman of
Planning ace so stepping in for chairman
Andy Crump we now move on to application
reference 18 forward slash zero three
two three nine /f ul the application is
the field between dog lane and fells
lane Knapton on the hill the description
the development self build three bedroom
house workshop and garage een with
access and parking plus improvements to
fells Lane including improved
resurfacing a turning head and a passing
place and now introduce Matthew coin to
present the application Thank You Jay
this application was originally before
the Committee on the 6th of February it
was deferred for two reasons one to do
with highways issues and one to do with
clarification over their housing needs
survey and housing numbers in that and
as it was a while ago I'll go through
the presentation from the beginning okay
so the the applications how it relates
to land to the east of fells lane on the
eastern side of the village of Nakhla on
the hill fells lane is a narrow track
which connects from dog lane to Vicarage
Road and it's indicated by the black dot
in the center of the screen there for
you so the red line shows the land as
part of this application the site
contains agricultural land
there's notable changes in land across
the site sort of sloping downhill
towards the south and southeast of the
site a public footpath runs along the
southern boundary just outside of this
site and that connects through from
Vicarage through to the Shiva Road just
beyond the screen there the site doesn't
contain any listed buildings and it's
not situated in any conservation areas
is however within the island stones Hill
a special landscape area this is an
aerial view of the site
so just indicating where the site is in
the center of the screen there he you
have undeveloped land to the to the east
with a couple of playing fields here the
land to the west of the site indicated
by those dots on the screen there he's
currently being out develop town for a
residential development of 28 units you
can see sort of dog lane along the
southern part of the site there so this
slide shows the draft built-up area
boundary for Knapton so it is in draft
form so it's only got limited weight but
it gives an indication of the direction
of travel for the built-up area boundary
of the village the red dot is indicating
where the site is situated so fells Lane
is the natural edge to the village as it
were there were the new development code
on sort of in that parcel of land there
the the playing field sorry to the east
of the site and not classed as built-up
for the assessment under the V UAVs this
shows the proposed site plan so you've
got some works going onto fells Lane at
the top here these indicating this or
the new development going on on the
opposite side this is the proposed
dwelling with a new workshop building
and a large garage here there's a number
of other sort of plant machinery across
the site which are indicated by these or
parts here so this is the proposed
elevation of the the new building this
is the main dwelling itself with a
workshop just in front here this is a
full set of the plans and elevations so
the garage building is on the right-hand
side of your screen with the workshop in
the top after so this is the view
looking south back downhill towards dog
Lane you can see a vehicle just in the
distance there that's dog lane and that
runs all the way along to sort of corner
at the screen over there this is again
looking sort of Southwest to the new
development going on the right-hand side
it's just taken a couple of months ago
so that
have come along a bit since then this is
a view looking north up fells lane
that's the bottom end of it which isn't
affected by the the development that the
upgrading to fells Lane is taking place
to the northern stretch of the look of
the lane this is again looking sort of
west back towards our side the sites on
the right-hand side and the new
development in the front there again
that was taken before the new houses
when ends or just behind that fence
looking north again back towards the
side of the site sort of just in the
foreground there there's some
agricultural buildings on the right-hand
side and they're sort of playing pitches
are beyond that and that's just looking
back towards a public right-of-way to
the south of the site just sticking sort
of indicate some of the changes in
levels across the site so there's a
detailed assessment the application and
that's in your agenda packet on page 25
there is an update as per the update
sheet and in that regard the development
requirements spt part s has now been
adopted and that carries full weight so
going to your assessments tonight so in
summary the principle of development in
this location is not considered to be
acceptable and there is not an
identified local news which supports
development here over the design scale
and in particular the siting of the
dwelling would have a detrimental impact
on the carrot to the area and the wider
landscape as such members are
recommended to refuse the application
for the reasons on page 37 of the agenda
thank you
Thank You Matthew I'd now like to invite
councillors Linda Goodrem and Gordon
Clark from maps and parish council good
evening to birth and thank you for being
patient li wei-ting you have three
minutes between you are you I'm just
speaking just you're speaking okay
whenever you're ready okay thank you
firstly we'd like to address the issue
of the housing needs survey the reason
the application
was deferred in February this year
Knapton perished 2018 housing these
survey highlights quite a high need of
24 homes this includes amongst others a
three-bed self built dwelling which is
the proposal of this application
although the scale of the development is
somewhat large for a three-bed property
however the fact that an identified
specific needs does not automatically
mean permission should be granted for
this application or any of the other 23
applications that may come forward
outside the be UAB or in open
countryside as it was previously known
in a similar way the fact that a need
has been identified in a survey it does
not automatically mean any and every
application that comes forward relating
to that survey is community led the
parish council having carry out the
recent housing needs survey is currently
in the process of preparing a
neighborhood development plan in full
consultation with the local community
the plan will address and deliver the
identified local housing needs through
the proper plan making approach the
process with robust community
consultation and engagement the
mechanism and responsibility for
addressing and delivering local needs
housing therefore rests firmly with the
Neighborhood Development Plan and not
through individuals promoting
speculative and planned development in
their own land and in this case outside
the Beav east of the natural village
boundary of felts Lane Charles Lane is a
nun sport feature of the village
residents do wish to keep and developed
not tarmacked
as there is very little traffic movement
at present along the Lane it is a safe
and popular walk to school route which
we compromise with extra traffic the
application was objected to by a Knapton
parish council and refused by head of
planning and he comments having viewed
the site satisfied that even without a
be UAB the same conclusions would have
been reached we would like the game to
point out the application is before the
committee solely
the reason that our ward member
councillor christyn Williams lent his
support to the application it is
disappointing that cancer Williams
offers no planning reasons why he
supports the principle in this
development which is contrary to this
cross strategy the conclusions are the
development is not currently led there's
been no community engagement it is
solely individually layered twenty
seconds the proposal conflicts with
politics yes 15 and a s 10 and his
outside the BtoB has stated by head of
planning in recommendation for a refusal
thank you perfectly times committee do
we have any questions Council O'Donnell
Thank You chef good evening can I check
has the applicant liaised with the
parish councils with yourselves about
the application no there's no
consultation me councillor Barnes living
the original plan there was one big site
which he split into two and the reserve
or no affordable I don't know whether
you were on the parish council thank you
sir I believe there's only four of
Banaras it the new development is
pointed out by Matthew which is
councillor Barnes this isn't an
affordable home this is it's a self
build three but large three-bedroom
building and he could any further
questions from members of committee
that's all thank you very much too much
now like to invite Roger Haley and Ben
Carol Vaughn
are you splitting the time between each
other or you are would you like a one
and a half minute though you have a
watch fine
whenever you're ready my name is Raja
hailey
I've lived in Upton since 1965 at the
top of fells land I've talked to a lot
of people I know a lot of people in the
village and I'm going to tell you now
what they've said to me the lane is
available I said you throughout the day
and it should stay as it is it's a safe
route to and from the primary school the
school also usually - spotted a
cross-country circuit into and out of
the sports field the usually just
increased since the completion of the
prize and Western Road development and
will increase further when the 28 icy
longhouses completed this summer
a big storm act then car access to the
score would also occur in the lane at
the same time as parents and children
are using the lane and it's far too
narrow below where they can to increase
the tarmac for pedestrians to be able to
step aside
also if permission were granted and
further applications would follow which
would be terribly difficult to refuse
the application includes turnaround
provision for the small refuse
collection vehicles to obviate reversing
of tour to the drivers they don't need
it they travel for top to bottom with no
need to reverse the village finds it
rather unfair and disappointing that
support for the application has come
from our ward member who does not live
in Upton and is not aware how the lane
is used our ladies and gentlemen the
obey these comments of mine when driving
in your decision and then reject the
application and
okay my name is Ben carve on I live on
Vicarage Road Knapton but immediately
adjacent to Rodger Haley at the top of
fells Lane my first point is that
neither Roger nor I objected to the AC
lloyd development of twenty-eight houses
currently under construction immediately
opposite this proposed development on
fells lane crucially although the AC
lloyd development is significantly
bigger and is ultimately closer to us we
accept that infill development is the
right way to meet housing needs the AC
lloyd development obviously lies within
the visual boundary of the village as
defined by fells lane irrespective of
any neighborhood planned boundaries mr.
Sanchez's application is outside of that
obvious boundary my second point relates
the comments received on the planning
portal I counted 20 comments in total
only 16 of which are from individuals
with a declared Knapton address of those
16 from Knapton 12 are objections and 4
are in support from this it seems clear
to me where community sentiment lies
thank you perfectly timed do members of
the committee have any questions they
wish to raise no thank you very much for
your time and for coming on this evening
now like to invite the applicant mr.
Michael Sanchez and mr. Jim sleight and
mr. Phil Revell and mr. Ellis Greenwood
chairman duppy three of us it's mr.
Sanchez the applicant mr. slate who's a
Knapton resident and myself Larry what
I'm the agent for you okay that's fine
thank you
we don't need we got written text so we
don't need any warnings of I'm speaking
on behalf of our application for a high
quality eco self built house in Knapton
so we can retire in the village where we
have lived for over 20 years we are
fully involved in the community life and
believe we have made a significant
contribution we note from the plan oh
please note on the plans the workshop is
better described as a plant room that
manages the machinery of the eco-house
the plot in question is the only
suitable land we have been able to
identify within the confines of the
village over the years we have spoken to
many landowners and the parish council
but no available plots have been
identified we have attempted to get
engaged with the parish council by
phoning the then chair corresponding
with the clerk sharing plans and designs
and also been open to dialogue we have
readily attended and spoken at three of
the parish council meetings and to date
have been offered very little limited
guidance by them and the planning
committee meeting in December they
singly failed to ask us or our architect
or our planning consultant one single
question through many consultations with
our district and county councillors we
have had very clear and helpful advice
from them health issues mean that is
difficult for us to downsize to a
speculatively built home as both myself
and our son who lives with us suffer
from a long-term chronic illness health
concerns as well as environmental issues
have highlighted the option of a high
quality self built home to passive
standards future proofing our home that
is both carbon
and energy neutral providing a healthy
environment for us to live in we believe
that self built homes with a strong eco
credential supported not only by
national government but also here in
Stratford we run a business in the
village employing 15 people and
categorically state that we are not
moving our business to this site we
believe that increased traffic from a
single home will be minimal and accepted
by high and has been accepted by
highways in conclusion we would just
like to build a home to retire in in our
village which we've been part of and
continue to contribute to that's it good
evening I've been a resident of Knapton
for about 30 years and I've undertaken
various voluntary roles in the community
including being a parish councillor and
also the chair of the parish plan
steering group which was adopted in 2007
and which still remains has a valid
reference document for local guidance on
planning matters
this application fits in very well with
this guidance it's of a unique design
contains many innovative elements and
will be a stunning asset for many years
to come it breaks the mold of the recent
generation of very boring its standard
packaged houses and it will easily merge
into the chosen location it is
disappointing to hear that our current
parish council has chosen not to engage
with the applicant to ensure they
receive support to optimize the proposed
self-build development and maximise its
impact on a piece of land currently
surrounded by other less visually
satisfying objects such as local
dilapidated agricultural buildings a new
housing estate and the lighting poles
and fencing of the sports facility which
you've seen on the diagram I trust that
the planning committee will support the
application thank you
German ask how many minutes I've got
left before I store it thank you - this
is a local need scheme and a self built
scheme supported by core strategy
policies s10 CS 15 which allow for this
sort of development outside of the
built-up area boundary wherever that may
be when it's finally drawn up there's
strong support for self-built housing
all levels of policy including in your
draft site allocation plan where policy
sa p1 allows for self-built housing on
the edge of villages outside of built-up
area boundaries and as quoted in the
officer's report policy a s10
specifically allows for quote
small-scale schemes for housing to meet
a need identified by the community in a
neighbourhood plan or other form of
local evidence on land within or
adjacent to a village this type of site
does not need to be within the village
boundary the 2018 housing needs survey
as noted by and accepted by the parish
council identifies a need for to self
build three-bedroom homes as well as
five other self build homes distinct
from any owner occupier homes you can't
and shouldn't dismiss the survey as the
officers suggest just because some
speculative homes have been built by a
developer in the village self build is a
different animal and the need is
identified in the survey being in the
survey which is quoted in the traffic
neighborhood plan the need has been
identified by the local community in
evidence as required by policy a s-10
Parish Council cannot be the sole
arbiter of what is local need a s10
makes it clear that is a matter of
evidence the SPD which has recently been
adopted so that ordinarily the parish
council would support that's an
explanation of policy s10 in CS 15 it
doesn't override them this is obviously
not that ordinary situation but the need
is still there in other
as agreed by officers mr. mr. Sanchez
meet the local connection requirement
and they're very much willing to sign a
section 106 agreement controlling future
sales to local people the house has been
carefully designed incited despite what
the officer says there is considerable
development to the east of the site
including the farm buildings and the
Sports Club the house is designed in the
local vernacular and was complemented
the design was complemented at the
parish council meeting I'm afraid we're
now time but thank you can we see
can I ask questions councillor Donnell
thank you
good evening I'm just a little bit
confused was there any liaison between
yourselves and the parish council
because I was led to believe that had
been engaged my wife is chair of
Governors at this primary school so
she's attended and I've attended over
the past two years I've stood up at
every stage and said I'm about to do
planning this was in March last year
Chris Williams who I believe written in
a letter gave me some guidance but I had
nothing back from we've had nothing back
from the parish council at all can I saw
one of the question how do you respond
to the concerns regarding the increase
in traffic with that being a walk about
300 meters long the top hundred is
already tarmacked with houses we're
proposing that the middle section be
tarmacked and that still leaves the
money section at the bottom which is
interact to be honest we'd be happy to
tarmac the bottom section but I mean the
truth is that it's a young name for the
lanes muddy lane
and I'd contest the fact that he's used
an awful lot and Jim's involved with the
school and he knows that it isn't used
widely by the children certainly not in
the winter you can see it on a daily
basis I think I think that's I think
we've answered the question sorry any
further questions from committee that's
all thank you very much indeed
now don't believe we have the ward
member here this evening and I don't
have a statement to read so we will move
swiftly on two points of clarification
with the officers counsel st. little
surprised to hear that the built-up area
boundaries still has limited weight in
its provisional now I know how long ago
we started on built up area boundaries
because I was personally involved but
can can we have some explanation as to
why that built-up area boundary has not
been settled thank you
yeah we'll pass that comment on to the
policy team obviously it hasn't been
adopted so it's not got full weight
before you tonight can pass on to the
policy team Thank You councillor st. any
other further council bond yes
affordable homes some of the
descriptions of the self build are
affordable because they're given the
land or that happened build hasn't got
the profit and I believe deuterium
Bambury built under the affordable home
system policy changed some weeks ago
didn't it what I'm asking is
it does have a counsel who's this cheap
mode or whatever you plan to call it
opportunity build for affordable homes
we can answer the question not entirely
sure that I understand it this is not an
application for an affordable home one
cheaper than would normally do
you know can I can I post a question to
officers that just like some
clarification around the local needs
scheme this house hasn't been submitted
as a local needs scheme has it with full
community support it's been submitted as
a self build scheme I think I think both
phrases have been used in the
description and development so it is a
self build and it is for a local person
so that the applicants have indicated
that they would sign under section 106
to tie it into a local needs scheme but
can I just have clarification on a local
needs scheme requiring community support
yes the city updates sheet just refers
to the development requirements SPD
which was adopted I believe last week
so that's part s and that relates to
general and local needs housing so in
there it says that in applying policy CS
50 in stratford-upon-avon district
council will attach significant weight
to the fact that a parish all the time
council is supportive of a net locally
okay fine but so the fact we haven't got
there isn't parish council support for
this and they haven't got a
neighbourhood plan identifying that any
further any further queries from any
councillor fielding you said that the
neighbourhood plan had been approved
yes there's a there's a part plan and
then there's a Knapton housing need
survey but there's not an adopted
neighbourhood plan have we done with
clarifications councillor Donnell did
you want to come back on it with this 15
and the update sheet regarding the fact
that the project needs community or
parish council support is that what
we're establishing because I'm just
confused as to what level engagement has
actually happened because those speakers
had contradictory reports on the level
of engagement between Parish Council and
applicant so just clarification on what
the update sheet means they for it to
qualify it you have the parish accounts
will have to be supporting that
community their project is that it's a
strong indicator of a local local need
scheme is that the parish council has
supported the application obviously the
update sheet says that that can be
written support or through a
neighborhood plan without that support
the advice that we've had is that it's
not the wouldn't fall within the ring
that locally scheme but actually both it
was a contradictory report wasn't it
between both speakers as to what level
of engagement to take in place it's
quite unusual that you have one person
saying they had engaged in another
person I think we're dragging into
debate I think we just need to need
clarification council filled the
application it seems to be is a self
built home but there's also the garage
and the workshop are those part and
parcel of the application or
they're already yeah that's part of the
application as well counselor Donald the
workshop was due to the fact that it was
an ecologically sound house wasn't it
it's not a business the workshop it's
all part of the the homes yeah right I
think we've covered that Thank You
Matthew we now move on to debate who's
who's happy to open councillor Barnes in
the respective I do know that the parish
didn't have a site for a certain amount
of houses sorry can I just ask for a bit
of quiet in the audience please sorry
it's very echoey and it comes back this
way if we can just give councillors time
to actually give their debate comments
forward thank you new policy which is
incorporated in some councils all the
affordable homes in my district they're
all sold at 60% no rent so there are
different types I think this is this
could be included in a further
application for affordable home under
the new system because it's going to be
a third that's to do or whatever because
you given the land who use your own
materials and I think that's the way the
government are going I'm sorry I can't
propose it because they'll haven't got
any other reasons only emotion so I'll
leave you to discuss it I think we just
need to reconfirm this is not affordable
this is self-build
okay this is not an affordable home
who else like to come forward
outside on it's just going back on this
the nitty-gritty regarding the CS 15 and
the support from the parish council I'm
just concerned with what level of
engagement that has been and would you
would you like to ask the council back I
would because it's quite available to
the update sheets information thank you
fine I'm happy to invite would members
of the parish council like to come back
and counselor Donna if you'd like to put
your question so can I just clarify how
much engagement took place because the
applicant has listed a number of the
meetings they they attended and the
plans that they showed so what level
engagement or phone calls a returned etc
so approximately a year ago maybe a
little bit longer I had a phone call I
was chairing for the parish council from
mrs. Sanchez who asked me if they were
considering the self-build property in
this location and I recall very vaguely
saying I will ask the other parish
councillors but I'm not hopeful that you
will gain support from parish council
subsequent parish monthly parish council
meetings mr. Sanchez he was invited to
speak about his application at the
meeting and again we said we would not
be able to support it because he was
outside of the building the proposed
built a very very boundary so can you
see my level of confusion because that
is engagement on the applicants behalf I
can and councillor Clark you realize you
made a mistake but that is that is
engagement but no time have we ever
given any encouragement they're two
totally different things though the
applicant has tried to engage with you
simply because you don't approve of it
does not mean it is a level of
engagement but I understand that you've
now explained that it's different but
they're two different concepts
I mean community engagement to us is one
thing if if we have planning if somebody
comes to us with an idea of what they
want to do maybe two
we were not engaged with them in a
private matter
only an open session but community
community engagement as far as we're
concerned has always been inviting the
community to an open consultation
session by us or the applicants we can't
until we get a planning application in
front of us which we will not discuss
details of what somebody wants to do and
did you have that planning application
in front of you we did via Stratford we
had the planning application in front of
us mr. Sanchez came to the meeting we
asked him questions about his planning
application can we just thank you all
right thank you thank you very much Dale
you just wanted to come back thank you I
think it was important to draw a
distinction and I think councilor Donna
was was drawing out that distinction
between community involvement and
community support and to clarify that we
have consulted with your policy team
with the housing in ableman officer
whose comment back to us was that on the
basis that the parish council have
objected to the proposal on the grounds
that it is not community led on this
basis alone I consider a refusal would
be justified so that's the straight
policy interpretation the level of
engagement is not relevant what's
relevant is the level of support and the
support is not there thank you does
anybody else want to make a comment I'm
quite I just like to save but say a
couple of things first of all I can I
can see the applicant has certainly
tried very hard they've identified
a site unfortunately
because it currently sits outside albeit
the draft built-up area boundary there
is no neighborhood plan there is there
isn't the community support for this
type of this application at this moment
in time as chair I'm certainly minded
and I appreciate it
you know it's the applicant has lived in
the village and we've we've heard all
the circumstances but I am minded to go
with the officers recommendation because
we do not have the reasons to overturn
the officers recommendation of refusal
but do we have a but do we have I'm
quite happy to propose that we go with
the officers recommendation do I have a
second I'm happy to support you in that
okay we have a proposer and a seconder
we now go to the vote all those in favor
of the vote to refuse planning
permission to write we go back against
against against for against that's
fallen fine do we have a an alternative
proposal do we still want to come on
continue with the debate
councillor bombs we just did the other
two were talking to say we've got a
proposal I think the best thing for this
application is to defer the application
the further development in the respect
of granting it then planning reasons
councillor bonds are you proposing we
defer it as far as I'm concerned the new
the new guidelines for affordable homes
one of them is self build because they
are usually if you like a third cheaper
or whatever
I appreciate what you're saying but and
they normally no in the village boundary
and as far as I'm concerned I feel it
could go through I proposed got the book
with all the paperwork in but if you
want to defer it for me to come back
with the councillor fielding ten to me
allows for small developments in the
countryside which is job creation and
therefore as I understand it this
follows along the line of a small
development in the countryside it's
within overlooking or overlooked by the
development that is taking place on the
opposite side of the road by C Lloyd it
I understand the fact that he has lived
in the parish for a good number of years
and he and his wife have taken part and
are very much involved in the business I
believe although I can't remember what
CS 15 says I believe that under a s 10
that we could grant it helpful if I went
through the relevant criteria in a so
that members before going through the
criteria can we just be clear this is
not an application for an affordable
house that's not what the applicant is
for put in front of us so we are not
considering affordable housing in the
planning sense of affordable housing it
may be more affordable but it is not an
affordable dwelling okay with that put
to one side in the countryside in
villages there are we're talking about
the following criteria for residential
development small-scale housing schemes
including redevelopment of buildings
within the built-up area boundary of a
local service village or otherwise
within the physical confines second
point conversion to a residential use of
a building within the physical confines
of a village third point conversion to a
residential use of a redundant or
disused building I won't read the rest
of that point because I don't think it
would help you next point a dwelling
which forms part of the conversion of a
billet building in the open countryside
again I don't think I need to go any
further
next point a replacement dwelling I
don't think I need to read any more
next point redevelopment of a bad
neighbor site again I don't think I need
to read any more a small-scale expansion
of an existing mobile home or park home
site next point a permanent dwelling for
occupation by a person engaged in an
agricultural occupation or
the form of use that can only reasonably
be carried out in the countryside
subject to a functional need being
established and final point a new single
dwelling in the open countryside which
is of exceptional quality and design and
makes a positive contribution to the
character of the area now before you you
go on to consider whether the final
point point Jay I'll read it again a new
single dwelling in the open countryside
which is of exceptional quality and
design and makes a positive contribution
to the character of the area they are
very very high tests to pass the
applicant hasn't applied under that
criteria and isn't suggesting that it is
an exceptional quality and design
although it is a very good dwelling a
very high quality dwelling he's not
suggesting that it doesn't fit within
that category councillor Fielding I
would argue that this would met within
the confines of the village it is you
have only the other side of it you have
the playing fields you have other roads
that are ring going round it which I
suppose that's a major road of getting
along at the top right hand corner but
this is very much in my view within the
confines of the village it it I would
argue that you've got dog lane you've
got the main road you've got first Road
which is part of the parish
I would think of Knapton and therefore
it's in the confines of the village I'm
just going to ask Dale to explain the
confines of the village Thank You Terry
so we've we've got some guidelines that
the council produced for defining
built-up area boundaries so I'll read
that in full for you so this is an
exterior answer defining built-up area
boundaries a built-up area boundaries
have been defined for
stratford-upon-avon and the eight more
main rural centres identified in policy
str1 much of the boundary line between
the settlement and the open countryside
is clear-cut however subjective
judgments have been necessary and
respect of some areas of land on the
periphery of settlements is important to
achieve a high degree of consistency
well except whilst accepting that some
cases a particular local interpretation
was justified as a guideline that the
land use is mentioned below where they
are located on the periphery of a
settlement were treated in the following
manner
so one including within this settlement
within the confines of a settlement our
church arts community buildings and
their immediate curtilage playing fields
are excluded from areas of residential
Kuragin estate these areas of clearly
products more appropriately defined as
non urban and then excluded from the
confines of assessment when on the edge
of the built-up area boundary our
playing fields including public private
and school playing fields there are the
uses such as modern agricultural
buildings and are the users councillor
fielding then councillor st. it's all
very well referring to as a built-up
area but I'm arguing the confines of the
village which is what was the
alternative for the a onv do you want a
moment should we that definition again
chef sorry
[Music]
thank you if I understood correctly
could counsel fielding you were saying
that you regard this site is within the
confines of the village I think that was
what you said yeah and they're the the
guidance that this council uses that
your policy team has prepared to decide
whether something is within the confines
of a settlement or without is as follows
is it a churchyard is it a community
building and its immediate curtilage but
it's not playing field and is it an area
of residential clear curtilage unless
it's clearly a paddock if it's any of
those things then it could be within the
confines of the village a churchyard a
community building or an area of
residential curtilage nothing else fits
within that catalyst categories this
isn't a churchyard it isn't a community
building and it isn't an area of
residential curtilage and then it goes
on to say what's excluded from the
confines of a bit of a settlement which
I don't think is helpful because we're
not talking about whether it's outside
we're talking about whether it's inside
is it a churchyard is it the community
building or is it an area of residential
curtilage if not it is outside the
confines of the settlement councillor
st. yes chairman I'm I'm starting to
concur with councillor Fielding here
because although it's outside the báb I
don't think he's satisfactory to be told
that we will ask the policy team mr.
Weiss taken so long or that I concede
that that will give us the most accurate
answer but effectively we have a
situation here where four of us voted
against refusal therefore and I'll tell
you my mind is thinking that perhaps
this application ought to be granted I
know it doesn't concur with your view
but so that's my view and effectively we
have an issue here because naps and I
believe is a local service village am i
right yes right so therefore that's
where built up area boundaries come from
yeah
s10 I can tell you because I helped
write it was effectively designed for
villages that don't have a built-up area
boundary it was designed for those other
places so therefore in that term we've
got a combination of the both as you
would expect probably from an isolated
village in a rural location so
consequently we have a situation whereby
I'm not sure that CS 15 really applies
at all but I think a s 10 could apply
and I think it's been onion unreliably
sort of set aside and also of course we
have cs5 and CS 9 which are often quoted
could you just come to the specific
point in a s 10 where you think this
application applies yes
well we've got the new single dwelling
in open countryside which is of
exceptional quality but importantly what
Matthew said was when he quoted the idea
of built-up area boundaries was some
subjective views have to be taken into
account and the subjective view here is
that we've got an applicant who clearly
got some form of medical issue and that
requires him to operate in this
particular area and I don't think that
we should throw people out of villages
for the simple reason that they have
some form I won't call it a disability
that would be offensive when he's sat
over there and I'm not sure the facts
but the point is we have to actually
show I think a little bit of compassion
in these circumstances also in ASN there
are requirements from business and he
has some sort of semi business activity
going on and effectively we can look at
business applications I think under IAS
10 and we can
therefore look at other issues I don't
counselor said we don't have to judge
the application on what is put in front
of us I know that please don't lecture
me I've been here long enough to
understand that now the situation is
that the the point of the issue is I'm
saying that we have got some subjective
thinking to do here we've probably got a
marginal case but I think we can argue
that marginal case and now I'll shut up
and let someone else have a go
councillor Donald woods es 9.5 be
relevant
sure I think it would be helpful if
councillor O'Donnell could pull out for
us in what way she thinks count the
policy CS nine point five is relevant my
reading of it is that all development in
the district whether it's inside or
outside a built-up area boundary whether
it's self built or not whether it's
affordable or not whether it's local
needs or not must comply with CS 9 all
development so this isn't in any way
special if it passes the principal test
being acceptable for other reasons then
we would expect it to comply with CS 9
in its entirety it's not contradicting
it we've obviously had quite a bit of
debate my proposal has fallen do we have
a proposal from other members of the
committee and the valid planning reasons
behind it can we argue that a s-10 as
outlined by a councillor st. is a valid
reason the grounds that it's within the
confines of the village it has got
special needs in with regards to the
family it's also got a small business
need and the man has been in the village
under a 106 for a considerable amount of
time I will ask the Planning Manager to
come back on this but yet again the
confines of the village needs of the
family business okay
I've read out to members of the criteria
to be used to decide whether a site is
inside or outside the built-up area
boundary and Matthew has shown you the
draft built-up area boundary which has
been drawn using those criteria and it
excludes the site if members consider
that this site is within the built-up
area boundary and the draft built-up
area boundary is wrong then I think
really members need to explain why they
think the draft built-up area boundary
is wrong and this will actually be
included within it that's the first
point so if you think it is within the
confines of the building of the built-up
area boundary you need to explain why
the second point is the needs of the
family again I think members need to be
very clear that the needs of this family
justify dwelling in the Auckland
countryside where a dwelling would not
normally be acceptable and I don't think
you've heard sufficient evidence to
satisfy yourself that this applicants
medical needs justify or require a
dwelling in this location I think it's
not too frivolous to say that we all
have medical needs
we all have medical problems of various
sorts what I haven't heard and what we
haven't seen the application is evidence
to suggest that that medical need leads
to a need for this dwelling I think
that's a second point and the third
point the small business we heard very
clearly from the applicant that the
small business and the dwelling are
quite separate issues the small business
is not moving to this site so again I I
think really the small business is not
something that members could use to
justify allowing this dwelling in this
location councillor Don thank you first
of all it's two questions what is the
point of this planning committee East
I'm picking up the frustration from the
top table about the fact that four of us
don't agree with your recommendation
and we are trying with our probably
quite limited experience compared with
your professional experience to explain
our concerns about it so I think the
committee is to discuss and raise our
concerns now I apologize that it's not
going along with what you would like us
to say on this matter but you know we
obviously for us have concerns and my
question is going back to your
recommendation regarding distinctiveness
and design you said the tests were very
high is this a sort of application would
at any point if it went back and was
discussed with you and they came back
with changes without ever meet those
kind of tests just be fair chair and I
just believe dial is trying to because
of the technicality of the policies I
believe is just trying to clarify that
succinctly for you I fully appreciate
that but the the the feedback that I'm
receiving not so specifically from Dale
is that people are frustrated that we
are not agreeing with what is expected
of us on this case and obviously four of
us or not are uncomfortable about
something but one point sure is that
council building did say can we argue is
10 so doubt did you know walk councilor
fielding through is 10 but it's up to
the councillors to actually come up with
a specific policy a point of that policy
it's not for the planning officers to
actually tell you the policy that you
should be taking council fielding first
thing councillor Barnes the built a
barrier boundary is not approved as yet
as I understand it and therefore I've
heard on a number of occasions it
carries limited weight we are in this in
the position here where there is limited
weight that can be leveled at it and
therefore as much as nails read out the
definitions under the built-up area
boundary I think in this instance we can
say
there can be we can't allow this
application nice and I propose it as
being to to be approved against the
officers recommendation fine so we we
now have I think the situation is I
propose deferment then the applicants
and everybody here is both sides and
they weren't expecting to be in this
situation then if we seize deferred
perhaps something can come forward
between all parties pursue to get this
result that's my personal opinion as a
way forward fine but just to come back
to counsel O'Donnell's query certainly
not getting frustrated all I was trying
to do was to encourage a proposal that
reflected our current policies for I
appreciate you you went against my
proposal I don't have a problem with
anybody coming forward with the proposal
but I just was I'm keen to have a
proposal that is backed up by policy and
planning reasons now I know John fear
the councillor fielding has said he
wants to propose just bear with me
councillor st. because that came forward
before that we had councillor Barnes
wanting to defer so I'm going to take
them one by one so councillor fielding
you want to propose granting application
does councillor fielding have a seconder
and what are the planning reasons for
granting application that's the st. you
want yes I'm happy to second councillor
fielding right and I would argue that
the built-up area boundary has limited
weight therefore we can argue that
perhaps he could be moved a bit
these towards in that diagram
secondly we do quote this counselor
Donna said cs9 if every application has
to apply for that that's what has to
apply we quote that as a specific reason
and then we say that there are certain
but specific local and medical needs
which justify granting this application
that's what I think should be our
reasons for support I'm being reminded
by our legal advisor on a write that in
fact it was councillor Barnes who first
put forward the proposal for deferment
but no one second to him has I will ask
the question has any does anybody wish
to second the deferment counselor Barnes
no so that fall so we come back to
counsel fielding and counselor st. you
you were happy to two second can we
please have the summation of the reasons
for going against offices recommendation
to grant planning application sorry
counselor st. I know this is going to
annoy you but I'm going to have to ask
you to go through it again because I'm
not entirely I got as far as the
variable boundary has limited wait yes
therefore we could assume it's in a
slightly different position to to what
it is
okay can you find a way of wording that
that probably makes it look you are here
to help and I do have some confidence
that you can do that right so the
situation is therefore so that's point
one the second point is counselor
Donald's point of cs9 if every
application that we grant has to comply
with CS 9 there's no point there's no
difficulty in us throwing that in as a
specific reason for this particular
application correct but it's not helping
you to overcome the principal objection
either well that's a point of view right
and as I said in your opening comments
mr. chairman Dale you you you you know
we are at liberty to make our own
recommendations and you know that we you
and I have had this conversation before
right so consequently my third reason
that was my second reason my third
reason was that there are special needs
involved with this particular family
that would rely on it being appropriate
I think to grant planning permission so
therefore we have to look the particular
requirements and I think they are
long-term requirements because let's
face it anybody can actually get
planning permission build something and
then move out well I don't think we're
going to get that in this case I
sincerely believe from what we've heard
tonight but the applicant is noting at
least so I think he agrees with that I'm
saying the right thing he is there for
the long term right if he gets
permission to build this house and
therefore I think we shouldn't be shy
about particularly quoting that so
that's well that's my three at the
moment if anybody wants to add to it
they're welcome to
Kendall I think there was some mention
made earlier of a possibility of tying
this to a letter to a local person
that's what capsule state was referred
to as well would that be sensitive 1:06
that we can arrange at this point in
this meeting yes it would be a local
need section 106 would guarantee it
would always be a local person well know
always they have to advertise it first
12 weeks to a local person and then
after that then they actually can
advertise that can be done in this
meeting tonight yes okay okay I think
I'm understanding what I'm hearing I
don't think that any there's a mood
amongst members to say that this site is
within the built-up area boundary I
think there is a mood amongst members to
say that this site is closely related to
the built form of the village and
therefore there'll be no harm from
developing this site which is very
different so that could be a material
circumstance indicating the permission
should be granted even though it's in
open countryside so that's point one
then we've got the the special needs of
the applicant again if you are satisfied
with those medical needs that again
could be a material consideration which
is which you're giving weight and which
goes into the planning balance and
finally the issue of local need if
you're you're satisfied on the local
need issue you could again give that
weight and those three reasons could be
your reasoning for granting permission
[Music]
I'm happy with that and also the fact is
the house does have insulation and it is
up to eco friendliness so I think
there's also that to be right so we have
the proposer happy we have the second
are happy let's go to the votes then we
have some conditions to
okay Frank Evans so the starting point
would be that any resolution you make is
subject to the signing of a section 106
obligation ensuring that the house
remains local needs swelling into the
future in the normal way but we don't
first point following that conditions
the normal start date condition tying
the applicant to the plans that he
submitted condition requiring submission
of material samples and descriptions yep
we think so
condition requiring details of the
access including to fells lane parking
and maneuvering all submitted to and
approved in writing by the local
authority provision of a construction
management plan prior to commencement of
development provision or a resolution of
Lankan contamination prior to
commencement of development and
remediation of any contamination that's
found landscaping scheme ecological
mitigation in accordance with 5.3 of the
appraisal that they submitted I think
it's mentioned in the report electric
vehicle charging point provision BIM
provision water bucks removal of
permitted development rights because
this is a very large chance and with
considerable site coverage and condition
limiting the use of the classic car
garage to private purposes ancillary to
the residential occupation or for the
dwelling and not for any business what's
or commercial purpose whatsoever and
then notes that the the public
right-of-way to the south of the site
should be kept open and free from
obstruction at all times the same
Chairman I think Dale missed out the
requirement to provide three wheelie
bins right so on that basis I invite
committee members to vote and this is in
favor of granting permission based on
the analogy that our planning manager
is given so all those in favor those
against abstentions
this this planning committee resolves to
grant planning permission for
application 18 forward slash zero three
two three nine /ql
now that's it we've got items of urgent
business
now items of urgent business
so I declare the meeting closed thank
you